ich sitze heute hier weil es mich sehr
bestürzt macht wie lang es dauert bis
politische Verantwortungsträger
eingestehen dass diese Impfstoffe mehr
Nebenwirkungen haben als wir gedacht
haben und das Kosten oder das
nutzenrisiko-profil nicht so gut
aussieht wie es uns oft gesagt wurde die
Aussage von Karl Lauterbach zum Beispiel
dass er zugegeben hat unter
Anführungszeichen dass es Nebenwirkungen
gibt und dann als Beispiel genannt hat
Menschen die sich nicht mehr so gut
konzentrieren können empfinde ich als
eine untragbare Verhöhnung gegenüber
Menschen die schwerwiegende Schäden von
den corona-impfstoffen getragen haben
die hauptsächlich auf
vorhersehbare und das werde ich noch
weiter ausführen
vorhersehbare Autoimmunreaktionen
zurückzuführen sind wie zum Beispiel
Thrombosen und Blutgerinnsel die bis hin
zum Schlaganfall führen aber auch
autoimmunbedingte Entzündungen im
Nervengewebe bis hin zum Rückenmark auch
hier gab es Alarmzeichen in den
klinischen Studien vor der Zulassung die
dann Menschen mit Lähmungserscheinungen
zurücklassen Menschen die Sport
betrieben haben und plötzlich im
Rollstuhl sitzen und da gibt es jetzt
auch aktuelle neue Analysen die eben
belegen die Impfstoffe haben mehr
Nebenwirkungen und diese Verhöhnung
gegenüber den Menschen die das erleben
müssen dass das immer wieder klein
geredet wird der möchte ich
entgegentreten die Verhöhnung der
Menschen das möchte keiner her aber ich
muss ehrlich sein als ich mir natürlich
mich auf sie vorbereitet habe habe ich
mich gewundert okay einer der größten
impfskeptiker im deutschsprachigen Raum
auf jeden Fall sind sie schon oft
aufgetreten haben gewarnt und sie sind
Öko Immunologe auf welcher Basis können
Sie so gut die Impfung einschätzen na
mein Thema ist das Immunsystem ich bin
auch Doktorand im Fach Biologie
am Institut für Biologie der Universität
Graz möchte aber betonen dass ich nicht
in dieser Funktion hier sitze aber ich
bin einfach von meiner Ausbildung her
Biowissenschaftler und mein Schwerpunkt
ist schon seit längerer Zeit das
Immunsystem die ökoimmunologie
Umwelteinflüsse auf das Immunsystem und
natürlich befasse ich mich da auch
im weiteren Sinne mit mit verschiedenen
Substanzen die auf uns einwirken und bin
da auch auf das Thema der Impfstoffe und
Medikamente gestoßen ich möchte aber
gerne klarstellen dass ich kein
impfscaptiker bin die einzige Quelle die
das behauptet ist Wikipedia aber ich bin
vor Corona nie die die Quelle meine ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht sondern ihre These
die Sie gerade vorgestellt haben da
kamen sie für mich als im skeptika dann
müsste ich ja das Prinzip der Impfung
in Frage stellen oder kritisieren mir
geht es aber hier darum dass
ich bin auch nicht gegen die
corona-impfung das Problem ist dass es
hier zu Verkürzungen zu teleskopierungen
zum zusammenschieben wie eine
Teleskopstange zum zusammenschieben von
Abläufen der impfstoffsicherheit
gekommen ist die normalerweise Zeit
brauchen und eingehalten werden wie zum
Beispiel dass man eine Phase kein eine
klinische Phase war noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen hat schon die nächste
begonnen und so weiter also wie ein
Teleskop wie die Glieder eines Teleskops
das nennt man teleskopierung wurden
diese
Zulassungsverfahren zusammen geschoben
es gab schon ganz früh und es geht mir
wirklich nur um diese Art von Impfstoffe
weil die so gepusht wurden weil da
plötzlich wichtige Prinzipien der
Sicherheit die mediale Kampagne
gigantisch und weil plötzlich wichtige
Prinzipien der impfstoffsicherheit an
denen man vorher nicht rütteln konnte
plötzlich über Bord geworfen wurden es
geht mir nur um diesen einen Tag dass
die Bürokratie einfach mal schneller
abgebaut wurde also jeder der Bürokratie
schon mal kennengelernt hat muss sagen
wir würden da viele Beispiele einfallen
wo man das glaube ich wenn die Krise da
wäre ganz schnell abbauen könnte kann
man nicht auch sagen dass deswegen die
Zulassungsverfahren schneller waren weil
einfach natürlich sind die Impfstoffe ja
auch zugelassen worden bevor die dritten
klinischen Phasen abgeschlossen waren
wie die laufen ja dann noch zwei Jahre
weiter manchmal sogar länger also das
sind ja Prozesse die noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen sind also allein das ist
schon ungewöhnlich aber auch eben das
einzelne z.B präklinische Phasen wurden
noch gar nicht end ausgewertet da wurden
die Impfstoffe schon an Menschen
verabreicht es gab schon sehr früh
stimmen die zweifeln diesen Impfstoffen
und an der Sicherheit geäußert haben und
in vielen Punkten auch recht hatten ich
selbst habe 2021 darauf hingewiesen dass
mit Autoimmunreaktionen zu rechnen ist
also Ende 2020 in einem Buch und in
einem weiteren Buch dann 2021 vor der
Zulassung also es war voraussehbar zum
Beispiel sie haben früher gesagt ich
möchte hier einmal einhaken damit wir
nicht ganz viele Punkte haben und dann
erst später Antworten
bitten also es ist jetzt gerade viel
aufgekommen Zulassungs gar nicht
vorbereitet er weiß ja unglaublich weich
gespült also unglaublich weil sonst
treten sie ja in YouTube und den anderen
Dingen deutlich heftiger aus als wäre
mir eigentlich ganz lieb gewesen sie
hätten auch mal ruhig rausgehauen also
Gott sei Dank sie kennen ja viele
Menschen also viele kennen sie und da
sind Sie ja schon ein bisschen heftiger
unterwegs was sie jetzt gesagt haben da
kann ich ja fast überall Haken hinter
machen ich finde das gut wenn man
kritisch ist und Sie haben Recht ich
sehe das genauso die gerade die Impfung
zu Corona die ich für eine Sensation
wirklich für fantastisch ist aber auf
der anderen Seite von bestimmten Kreisen
sehr gepusht worden auch da wäre mir
lieb gewesen man hätte nicht immer den
Eindruck gehabt und es wurde zum Teil ja
auch so gesagt ja da gibt es vielleicht
schon irgendwas aber das haben wir bei
anderen informiert das dürfen wir jetzt
aber hier nicht so erwähnen weil das
gibt dann Echo in der falschen Kammer
das halte ich auch für absolut
kritikwürdig und deswegen ist es in
Ordnung kritisch da heranzugehen aber
sie sind schon ein nicht nur im
Skeptiker sondern sie sind schon auch
ein was naja also was die corona-impfung
angeht über die anderen Impfung
allerdings schon in einer recht heftigen
Weise und da kam mir so in den Sinn mit
Herrn Lauterbach habe ich ja auch so
meine eigenen Gedanken und ich glaube
viele von uns eine eigentliche Fanbase
hat er ja inzwischen verloren da gibt es
noch eine Runde fragen vielleicht ist ja
der letzte Fan von Karl Lauterbach
im Prinzip sind sie für mich jetzt nicht
heute hier das muss ich sagen aber sonst
sind sie für mich der Lauterbach unter
den
impfskeptikern bzw Corona im Skeptiker
Prognosen sind nicht eingetreten nein er
hat ihn den YouTube-Videos genau das
gemacht was er Lauterbach umgekehrt auch
macht er ist ein Cherry Picker sie
wissen genau was das ist also ein
herausgreifer der einzelnen Aussagen aus
Studien die einem Behagen die einem
gerade in die Richtung gehen und das
Weglassen andere Teile ist gehört immer
nein nein dazu und sie schreiben wir
jetzt gerade ihre Dissertation über ich
glaube zirbelwälder und Einfluss auf den
Menschen das ist nicht der Grund weshalb
sagen muss der Mann hat keine Ahnung es
gibt Journalisten die kommen vor ganz
woanders Theo und haben sich super toll
in die mna Technologie eingearbeitet
doktoratsarbeit über den Einfluss von
Umweltfaktoren auf das Immunsystem ja
also das wie gesagt ist mit Sicherheit
auch kein kein Grund dass man da dann
keine Ahnung haben könnte aber man muss
natürlich schon gerade wenn man solche
Studien dann zitiert komplett zitieren
und wenn man die Studien meistens im
Abstract mal anschaut dann steht dann
meistens sogar das genau die Aussage die
sie daraus lesen wollen genau nicht mit
dieser Studie zum Beispiel
Langzeiteffekte herauszulesen sind ich
gebe Ihnen Recht man hat die Sache zu
einseitig gesehen ja ich sage ja heute
sind sie hier also
vielleicht sollte ich ja mal was sagen
das Problem ist wir sind jetzt hier
nicht in der Lage in der Sendung jede
Aussage von Herr Arbeit durchzugehen das
heißt ich weiß jetzt nicht woher Cherry
pricking betrieben haben soll da muss
ich ihn jetzt erstmal ein Schutz nehmen
kann ich nicht sagen dass das stimmt der
Vorwurf aber machen wir es mal ganz
konkret Herr sprecht weil viele Bürger
haben ja wirklich Angst vor der Impfung
oder sagen auch sie wollen die vierte
jetzt nicht mehr haben das sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge genau weil würden Sie
denn jetzt zum Beispiel mir als
30-jähriger Frau raten die vierte im
Funktion machen nein nein und Herr
Arbeit wird es mir auch nicht raten nein
kann ich Ihnen nur meine privaten
gefährlich ist sondern weil sie ich
kenne sie jetzt nicht wir gehen jetzt
davon aus ich sie sind total gesund
total jung 20 gerade überschritten dann
ich haben sie einfach nichts davon eine
Impfung ist ein Benziner wenn man sofort
einig ja medizinischer Eingriff und das
ist eine tolle Sache ist es wirklich
sensationell was da gelungen ist ich bin
absolut davon überzeugt der mna-impfung
über die vektorimpfung ist wieder eine
andere Geschichte sie hatten über
Thrombosen gesprochen anderes Thema aber
die mna-impfung hat
zig Millionen wahrscheinlich hunderte
von Millionen Menschenleben gerettet
aber sie haben aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach nichts von einer vierten Impfung
von der dritten wahrscheinlich schon
aber von der vierten nicht warum sollte
man es dann also tun sie könnten
Nebenwirkungen haben haben Sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber sie haben
keinen keinen keine Mehrwert davon wären
sie jetzt 85 und hätten
Begleiterkrankungen und hätten die
anderen Impfungen aber auch gut
vertragen und vielleicht hätte man sogar
eine Antikörperbestimmung mal gemacht
dann sei die Sache vielleicht ganz
anders aber genau das wurde er nicht
gemacht es wurde ja nicht selektiert es
wurde eine Impfung ausgerollt im
Politiker für alle bis zu den Kindern
auf Basis teleskopiert der Verfahren das
halte ich für absolut fahrlässig jetzt
aber zu den zwei drei wichtigen
Beispielen weil ich muss ja auch
irgendwas sagen wo sie dann
widersprechen bitte
zum Beispiel hat man
gesehen bei astroseniker zum Beispiel
hat man gesehen in den in den klinischen
Phasen Veränderungen im Blutbild die
hingewiesen haben eine sogenannte
Neutropenie ein deutlicher Abfall
bestimmter weißer Blutkörperchen die
darauf hinweisen dass da eine
Überschüsse überschüssige überschießende
Immunreaktion angelaufen ist und was
wäre an sich aufgrund dieser Signifikanz
im Vergleich zu anderen Impfstoffen ja
das haben die Autoren selber als
signifikante Häufung dieses Vorfalls
angegeben schon ein Alarmzeichen gewesen
was ist die wo kommen diese
Blutgerinnsel die Thrombosen die auch
ins Gehirn gehirnven betreffen her es
ist eine überschießende
Autoimmunreaktion eine thrombotische
Thrombozytopenie das Immunsystem greift
die eigenen Thrombozyten an und dadurch
kommst zu diesen Störungen man hatte man
intellektuell bei den Fremdwörtern muss
ich Ihnen diese Art nicht konkret aber
diese Art der Autoimmunreaktionen an den
frühen klinischen Studien bereits sehen
und ich und andere die darauf
hingewiesen haben sind sofort ins Eck
der schwurbler gestellt worden sofort
entdeckt der alu-träger Querdenker
obwohl ich zu meinem ganzen Leben davor
nicht dann noch nie gehört habe was
Querdenker überhaupt sind aber es waren
Dinge
vorhersehbar wie zum Beispiel diese
überschießenden Autoimmunreaktionen und
wie gesagt diese Blutgerinnsel diese
diese die auch bisschen zu
Schlaganfällen führen das sind
Autoimmunreaktionen in der Ursache
aufgrund der Impfung es gibt auch
Menschen die im Rollstuhl plötzlich
sitzen die Lähmungen haben aufgrund von
Autoimmunreaktionen im Nervengewebe bis
hin zum Rückenmark und da gab es auch
frühe Hinweise früher Hinweise in
klinischen Studien das
rückenmarksentzündungen aufgetreten sind
und man hat es nicht man hat man hat es
man hat es zur Seite geschoben man hat
es gleich weggewischt anstatt diese
Warnsignale ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen
wir müssen besser selektieren wer die
Impfstoffe bekommt und werden zusammen
dass man differenzieren muss wer es
bekommt und wer nicht und vor allem dass
man nicht alle über einen Kamm hätte
scheren